I need like floaty yack Co deathly
hallows Oh John it's July 18th I have a
lot of really good news for you
a year ago today I recorded the song
that pretty much changed my life I was a
song about Harry Potter and it came out
right before Harry Potter and the
Deathly Hallows came out and I was
really excited and so to celebrate the
anniversary of the song changed my life
I'm running another song about Harry
Potter also I want to thank the
nerdfighters for working together to get
a Cu Deathly Hallows up to 1 million
views that's a pretty good anniversary
present and to say thank you I have
finally I think figured out a way to fix
my pants you don't know what that means
that's okay but if you do then you know
that it's really good news because my
pants has always been central to the
nerdfighter community and for a long
time a lot of people have been locked
out spam filter was out of control and I
think I've had it under control
so you get a song and you get my pants
back and I hope that you enjoy them
though
cue the music
I know I'm not the only one who wants to
know more about Harry Suns
I really do you think that there's an
unwritten story I think it's time to put
fingers two keys I know a lot of people
probably want to know more about
Grindelwald and Dumbledore I believe you
think that they go bad and Lefty
and I took this probably a good story
there
for good game I wanna bug a I wanna
forget and I'm gonna take caroling to
say that the epilogue was crap cuz we
all know him is crapping I'm on JK
Rowling to say that no Mort had a son
and the story's just begun and I'm on JK
Rowling to say that she's writing boogie
I know a lot of people probably want to
hear the tale of the mysterious fail I
believe you think it's a dimensional
portal and I think series is in
middle-earth and I know I wanna hear the
one about Hagrid stat Nagraj mum I
really do you think that that's nearly
impossible and I think there's probably
a good story there
for booking I wanna book a I wanna book
date and I want a caroling to say that
the epilogue was crap because we all
know it was crap in I want JK Rowling to
say that the Mort had a son and the
story's just begun and I'm on JK Rowling
to say that she's writing boogie she can
call it Harry Potter and the pillar of
story or Harry Potter and map of the
realm of Narnia or Harry Potter and the
starfighters of a jamar or Harry Potter
and the Paper Towns or Harry Potter and
the Knights huseyni or Harry Potter nerd
fighters or hey
Oh
one of a game
I really do think there's an unwritten
story and I think it's down to four
fingers to keep
for book eight thank you all for an
amazing nuisance Accio Deathly Hallows
and thank you all for an amazing
nerdfighter experience in general I hope
that you enjoy my pants and I hope that
you enjoyed that song and John I'll see
you soon
punish me for being over four minutes
there was indeed a montage my goodness
for the montage exception or the sons
would be hard okay bye